you talked about parenting the first
thing I did when I had my kids was I had
their chart on I wanted to know who I
was Raising I wanted to know okay so
like what what is the energy of this kid
like how how do we communicate with them
you think that they had past lives are
they somebody that existed before I
believe we all are I don't know who they
were and that was something that I was
actually very so see that's a great
question how that's an amazing question
nobody's ever asked me um I'm really
good at this you really are um I never
wanted to know who they would have been
cuz that to me is not important to who
they are now and the blueprint of the
lifetime that they're living and they're
supposed to achieve here so I think that
and I think it's because like you I've
been doing this for a long time you know
like I I now have people coming up to me
that are saying the things that I want
to apologize to people that I used to
say like when I would meet like like a
soap actor in the city walking in
Manhattan I'd be like oh my God I watch
you with my grandma you know and I I
would mean that as an endearment and now
I have people coming to me they're like
oh my God I watched you with my grandma
and now I hear that differently
um but there's there's a a level of
understanding who they are in this
lifetime and wanting to make sure that I
have them on path and help them for who
they are here so they can in their own
you know way learn that but doing this
for as long as I've been doing it I went
through the past life craze where
everybody and their brother were like
getting weekend hypnotherapy
certifications so they can teach you how
to stop smoking lose weight and find out
what you are in a past life and I'm like
yeah no that's not the person I would
send you to I'd send you to the
psychologist who has a background in
hypnotherapy who has a practice in
dealing with past life aggression
therapy you know Allah Dr Brian Weiss um
or somebody that is got letters before
and after their name like because
there's there's a difference between the
person who's doing the fortune telling
and then the person who's doing
legitimate readings in every field right
were your kids ever scared of what you
do no no I think my daughter had one
experience that was uncomfortable and um
my wife and I felt a little bit bad
about it because we didn't cuz she
really really was theatrical as a kid
like she was very much the dramatic
child like I have a very strong image of
being like out in public in a restaurant
and she was like very performative and
just like I had that moment of like
going oh my God like how did I have that
child like how did it like how did the
universe send me her like this is this
there had to be a mistake like this is
not the child I should be raising um and
I remember having this moment of
like okay and then she was like two and
she didn't want to sleep in her room she
was afraid to sleep in her room because
of the beers oh well she would say what
she said the beers yeah she was like
there's beers in there I was like beers
and in my head I'm like my dad was an
alcoholic and he did like a lot of beer
I go maybe that's like a simple he's
trying to like maybe she's I'm literally
trying to figure out like what the beers
were and this went on for like maybe a
good year and a half to two years and I
just looked at it as she wants to be in
the family bed like she wants to be like
in the bed with Mommy and Daddy and I
think cuz I would travel so often you
know she would sleep with Sandra and
that that that now I'm home and it's
like move over Dad I'm afraid of the
beers like so I was like whatever and
then a colleague of mine her name is
Char Margolis and she's somebody that I
love and respect slept at my house and I
was like Olivia sleep in our room you
can sleep in her room and next morning
she said um would you mind if I slept in
a different room is there a different
room I can sleep in and I was like why
is it like too hot in there I'm thinking
like temperature she does want to sleep
in a room you know like that's a kids
room she's like no she was like I was
having I don't know if she said she was
having nightmares of bears or she was
seeing bears and Sandra and I like
looked at each other and I was like bear
and she goes yeah she's like hasn't
Olivia ever complained about the Bears
and we just had this like moment of like
holy crap and then I felt bad because
when I was a kid I used to see a wolf
that's the size
of that Bobby Bobby Bobby as and as a
kid how tall would you say that is four
feet
U yeah okay okay five five feet okay I
don't know why I care about the height
you think Bobby is four to five feet so
imagine if your bed is across the room
and then you you know you're trying to
sleep at night and there's a wolf that's
that size staring at you that would
bother most children I didn't sleep like
that freaked me out as a child and then
that's why I have a great understanding
of kids being afraid of energy what was
the meaning behind the Bears or the wolf
so I now know right after years of doing
this that apparently we all have like a
spirit animal or a spirit totem that
we're connected to mine apparently was
the wolf now did I learn that at 16 no I
learned that close to 30 when I was
doing a book signing and a shaman came
to my event and I was sitting at a desk
like this and he walked up to me hands
me the book and he looks to my left and
smiles there's nothing here like there's
nothing visibly to me that I can see
smiles and then he looks back at me and
like nods and I went what and he goes I
see you walk with the wolf in this
life and I can't explain it I like I
kind of became like a 5-year-old in
front of this man because nobody
believed me my mother didn't believe me
my father didn't believe me nobody
believed me they all thought I wanted to
get in their bed too like that I didn't
want to sleep in my in my my big boy bed
and I was like no I loved my room I
loved my space I just didn't love that
there was a wolf in my room because he
was the he was the villain of all the
stories as a kid the big bad wolf was
going to eat you three little pigs you
know like
right that you know we had a similar
story you you had a similar story not
with a wolf no to the Bears the man with
the beard oh yeah but it wasn't an
animal I didn't have a spirit animal but
we ended up moving right because of the
man I had a similar story where she kept
crying about a a man with a beard and
then um
one of the ladies that helped us take
care of her ended up sleeping in that
room and said did you ever see the man
with the beard and you were like I'm out
yeah and then we were at another place
and there was a picture and she started
screaming that's the man that's the man
there was a picture of a man with a
beard and so I sold the
house